[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من الرياض
والتي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار وملفات
السعوديه والخليج اليكم العناوين
العربيه ترصد الاوضاع على حدود اوكرانيا
مع بيلاروسيا في ظل مخاوف فكيف من هجمات
حدوديه
الحج السعوديه تعلن بدا تسجيل حجاج الداخل
ضمن اربع عباقات تبدا تكلفتها من 4000
ريال
الشؤون الاسلاميه في السعوديه تعلن رصد
تحديات على عدادات المياه والكهرباء في
عدد من مساجد العاصمه
ومن ملفاتنا المتنوعه في الرابعه
احسن السعوديه تعلن عن تجاوز التبرعات
المليارين و 900 مليون ريال في اكثر من 23
مجالا
وفيديو ويوثق تساقط الثلوج على المرتفعات
جبل اللوز في اليوم شمال غرب السعوديه
مساء الخير عزاز الجيش الاوكراني من
تواجده في الحدود مع دوله بيلاروسيا عبر
انشاء دفاعات الهندسيه وزرع الالغام وذلك
على كامل الحدود بين الدولتين خشيه الزحف
لك من الجانب البلاروسي واوضحت
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه في ما
سبق الناموس كوستخدمت بيلاروسيا منطلقا
للحرب بعد نشر الالاف من قواتها في الحدود
واطلقت صواريخ من قواعد جويه بلا روسيه
رئيس الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
رجعها ان تكون هناك ضربات اخرى في عمق
الاراضي الروسيه من دون ان يحدد ما اذا
كانت اوكرانيا ستقف ورائها ولم تعلن
اوكرانيا مسؤوليتها عن الهجوم الذي وقع في
السادس والعشرين من سبتمبر على قاعده
انجليز الجويه الروسيه والتي تقع على بعد
اكثر من 800 من الحدود الاوكرانيه لكن
بذنوب اعترف بانه سعيد برؤيته حسب قوله
كشف قاده قاده عسكريون اوكرانيون
جورنال بان القوات الروسيه خففت من هجومها
على مدينه باخموت في شرق اوكرانيا وحولت
قوتها الناريه الى مناطق محيطه واشار
العسكريون الاوكرانيون الى ان روسيا لم
تعد تهاجم مدينه بخموت الاستراتيجيه
بشراسه نفسها التي كانت عليها الشهر
الماضي وتقوم بدلا من ذلك لتغيير مواقع
الدبابات والمدرعات والمدفعيه باتجاه بلده
سوليدار القريبه حيث تسعى روسيا الى
اختبار الدفاعات الاوكرانيه حولها واكدت
وصفه جونير انا هذه الاشارات تعبر عن تخلي
روسيا عن هدف الاستيلاء على باخمود
بالكامل
ينضم الينا من الحدود الاوكرانيه
بيلاروسيا مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل اهلا
بك معنا حذيفه في نشره الرابعه اذا ما
الذي رصدته حتى الان على الحدود
الاوكرانيه البيلاروسيا حذيفه
في النقطه الحدوديه بين اوكرانيا
وبيلاروسيا على بعد 400 متر فقط في هذا
الاتجاه
الاراضي الروسيه طبعا يمنع طبعا توجها
الكاميرا في هذا الاتجاه ولكن هنا طبعا
توجد تعزيزات كبيره جدا للجيش الاوكراني
في هذه الحدود ايضا اخبرني الضابط هنا في
الموقع قال ان جميع الحدود هي ملغمه
بالالغام كذلك يوجد نقاط لعمليات تمشيط
وكان على المسطحات المائيه طبعا هنا يوجد
نهر النيبر الذي يفصل ايضا بين دوله
اوكرانيا ودوله روسيا كذلك بعد انتهاء
منطقه المسطحات المائيه بعد ذلك هنالك
حدود حوالي 1000 همم كلمتر تفصل بين
البلدين ايضا يوجد نقاط مركز ايضا قاموا
كما قال لي بقطع الاشجار في الغابات التي
تفصل بين البلدين في المناطق التي همم
يتمركز في تمركز فيها القوات
مساحه اوسع للرؤيه وهم يراقبون على مدار
الساعه تحركات القوات البلر الروسيه
والروسيه في همم تلك المنطقه وقال اننا
نستطيع ان نراهم بالعين المجرده ونرسم
تحركاتهم وايضا نقوم بمراقبه الاجواء
لاغلاق الحدود بشكل كامل حتى الان همم هم
مطمئنون على ان الحدود لا توجد اي خروقات
لا توجد اي عمليات تسلل من قبل القوات
وكان الروسيه الروسيه او حتى
المدنيين لم تصل اي عمليات تسلل وقال ان
حتى الان هنالك احكام سيطره كامله على
الحدود ولكنهم جاهزون لجميع السيناريوهات
يتوقعون طبعا هذا الحديث ايضا افادت به
كيف افاده بين رئيس الاسكي الرئيس
الاستخبارات العسكريه قال انه هنالك
قد تكون امكانيه لزحف جديد داخل الاراضي
الروسيه نحو كيف طبعا هذه الحدود هي
الاقرب الى كيف حوالي ثلاث ساعات من هنا
من هذه النقطه همم الى العاصمه اكيد كذلك
سيناريو اخر طبعا ان تدخل القوات
الاتجاه نحو الولايات الغربيه والسيطره
ومنع وصول الامدادات من الغرب همم من
الدول الغربيه من الاتحاد الاوروبي الى
داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه وبعد ذلك الوصول
طبعا الى الشرق الى جبهات الشرق هذا هو
الوضع حتى الان رايت ايضا بعيني وانا وانا
في طريقي الى هنا رايت كيف تقوم القوات
بعمليه تلغيم للجسور والطرق وزرعه الاغنام
يعني هذا امر وشاهدناه هو نحن
نعم تحدث عن القوات الاوكرانيه التي
مازالت تواصل عمليه زرع الالغام حتى ان
الجنود قالوا لنا التحرك في اي مكان لم
يتم السماح بها او لم يتم اخبارنا
بامكانيه التحرك فيه سيكون خطيره جدا لذلك
لا نتحرك الالعاب المنتشرها قبل ان ينتهي
وقتنا عن تصريحات بوتن الاخيره عن انهم لن
يتناولون عن الاراضي المنضمه الى روسيا في
اي مفاوضات قادمه هل من ردود فعل رصدتها
داخل اوكرانيا حول هذه التصريحات الاخيره
صحيح طبعا هذا الامر مرفوض تماما من قبل
السلطات الاوكرانيه ابتداء من الرئيس
بلادي ميرسي وجميع ال ال ال المسؤولين في
مكتب الرئيس كذلك في برلمان الشعب
الاوكراني تحدث
واعلق عدد من البرلمانيين حول هذا الامر
ايضا رصد رفض واسع من المواطنين اسمه كان
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي او بالحديث
المباشر اليه وهم يرفضون ان يكون هنالك اي
تنازلات همم اي مفاوضات تتنازل عن الاراضي
التي همم نتحدث عنها وهي المناطق الاربعه
طبعا دروس
ويقولوا مع انه سوف يقاتلون حتى الوصول
الى الحدود المعترف بها همم دوليا وهذا
الامر همم في الوقت الحالي طبعا هو مرفوض
من قبل الجانب الاوكراني وهو ليس من ضمن
همم
الرؤى التي تضعها كييف لي الحلم شكرا لك
من الحدود الاوكرانيه البيلاروسيا مراسل
العربيه حذيفه
اعلن عن الكرملين ان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ابلغ الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان باستعداده للانفتاح على
الحوار مع اوكرانيا اذا قبلتك كيف باعتبار
الاراضي الواقعه تحت سيطره موسكو بانها
روسيه واضاف الكرملين في بيان ان بوتين
اكد مره اخرى في تحروسيا على الحوار الجاد
بشرط ان تفي سلطات كيف بالمتطلبات
المعروفه والمعبره او معبره مرارا عن
مراعاه الحقائق الاقليميه الجديده وفقا ما
جاء في البيان
ينضم الينا من موسكو مراسل العربيه عبد
الجواد الرشد اهلا بك معنا عبد الجواد
ماذا لديك حول تصريحات بوتن الاخيره هل
بالفعل يتوقع ان تتنازل كيف عن هذه
الاراضي التي رفضت مرارا وتكرارا التنازل
عنها
اليوم والرئيس الروسي
حديثه مع الرئيس ونظيره التركي يتحدث عن
نيه موسكو موافقتها على البدء او العوده
للحوار مع الجانب الاوكراني وطبعا العديد
من الملفات تقف خلف حديثه طبعا بوتين اكد
على ضروره الاخذ بعين الاعتبار جميع
الخطوات وما التاليه الاعمال العسكريه في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه من سيطره روسيه على
المناطق الاربعه وضمها لكيان الاتحاد
الروسي موسكو طبعا
تشترط عدم وضع اي شروط تلزم موسكو بالخروج
من تلك المناطق وهذا الشيء طبعا كما نتابع
ترفضه كيف لذلك طبعا همم الطرق حتى هذه
اللحظه كما يرى المجتمع الروسي للوصول الى
حلو الجلوس لطا مفاوضات هي مسدوده نوعا ما
يعني هي طريقه مغلقه ما تتحدث الدائره
السياسيه في البلاد خاصه ان بين موسكو
والغرب اليوم كيا واشنطن ولندن وباريس و
برلين اصبحت توجد ازمه لعدم الثقه بين كل
هؤلاء الاطراف فاطمه طبعا في نقطه اخرى
مرتبطه بالحوار وجلوس طاوله المفاوضات
الكنيسه الروسيه اليوم دعت طبعا كل
الاطراف المتنازعه في الازمه الاوكرانيه
لاعلان هدنه لوقف اطلاق النار بشكل كامل
اعتبارا من يعني ظهيره السادس من الجهر
الجاري وهو يوم الغد باعتبار ان الشعب في
روسيا واوكرانيا يحتفلون بعيد الميلاد
ليله السابع من هذا الشهر الجاري هو اعلان
هذه حتى نهايه يوم السابع لم
اي تعليقات لا من قبل موسكو ولا من قبل
كيف
عفوا فاطمه لما اسمع السؤال
عندما يخرج مثل هذا البيان من الكنيسه
طبعا وهو
الشخصيه الاولى كيريل في بما يخص هذا
الموضوع يكون هذا الاعلان بموافقه موسكو
لكن حتى هذه اللحظه لا موسكو ولكن اصبحت
تتحدث عن احتمال دخول الطرفين في هدنه لكن
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي اصبح يتحدث
الشعب الروسي بانه يامل في اعلان هدنه
لعلها تقوم يعني بصفه العداء انصحها
التعبير للايام القادمه
بالمفاوضات والموافقه على البدء
بالمفاوضات بشروط معينه هل يعني انا موسكو
اكتملت الاهداف العسكريه او للعمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا لها
فاطمه يعني هذه التصريحات من قبل موسكو
تتكرر بشكل يومي كامل ان العمليه العسكريه
مستمره حتى نهايتها وهدفها نزع السلاح من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه احلال والسيطره على
كافه المناطق التي ضمتها موسكو لذلك طبعا
موسكو جاريه في العمليه العسكريه ان كان
الكرملين او كان رئيس البلاد او الدفاع
اوالخارجيه تتحدث بشكل يومي عن نيتها
للمفاوضات لكن تتحدث ايضا عن استمرارها في
العمليه العسكريه ونلاحظ طبعا منذ راس
السنه بعد الضربه الاوكرانيه ومقتل
العشرات وجرح عشرات اخرين في دانيسك
العمليات العسكريه الروسيه تشهد تصعيدا
كبير الارقام كبيره ريان وزاره الدفاع
يوميا اصبح يتحدث عن تحييد واصابه وجرح
اكثر من 400 شخص في كل يوم حتى يوم الامس
شهد جرح واصابه قرابه 500 شكرا
بيعدل جواد الرشد على هذه المعلومات
كشفت وزاره الحج والعمره عن انخفاض تكاليف
حملات الداخل بنحو 30 في المئه ياتي ذلك
مع بدء اتاحات التسجيل المبكر للحجاج او
حجاج الداخل تحديدا الكترونيا والوزاره
كشفت في بيانها الصحفي الصادر اليوم عن
اتاحه اربع باقات لحجاج الداخل تبدا
تكلفتها من اربعه الاف ريال كما اشارت
الوزاره الى امكانيه دفعها جزئيا على ثلاث
دفعات معايره التسجيل لهذا العام تتطلب
واكمال جرعات كرونه واشتراف 12 عاما كحد
ادنى للمتقدم لطلب الحج اضافه الى اعطاء
الاولويه لمن لم يسبق لهم الحصول على
التصريح والوزاره كذلك شددت على ضروره
التعاقد مع الشركات المرخص لها والمدرجه
في موقعها الالكتروني
في حديث ان العربيه قال نائب وزير الحج
والعمره عبد الفتاح نشاط ان السعوديه
ستواجهه تحديا كبيرا في حج هذا العام
والذي اوضحت المؤشرات بشانهم ارتفاع اعداد
الحجاج لتصل الى ما قبل رائحه كورونا طبعا
نحنا نعمل ان شاء الله باذن الله بعد من
خلال يعني المؤشرات جيده كلها اننا
نستقراها من الجاي يحط كرونا همم ان احنا
نعمل ان شاء الله باذن الله للعوده لما
قبل الجايه واكيد هذا اكبر التحديات اللي
كنا نحنا في السنوات الماضيه او السنه
الماضيه تحديدا ان كنا ما واجهناه للاعداد
الكبيره في الحج هذه السنه هيكون العدد
اكبر اكيد حيضيف علينا تحدي اكبر كيفيه
الموازنه والتوازن بين عدد الحجاج مقابل
الخدمات اكيد هذا حتكون تحدي كبير جدا
لمقدم الخدمه والجهات التي تشرف على
مقدمين الخدمه
نحنا توجهنا هذه السنه الى اربع باقات
رئيسيه
لمقدمه لضيوف الرحمن من داخل المملكه
العربيه السعوديه تبدا
بالباقه اللي هي التي سيتم تقديمها من
خلال الابراج الموجوده في مينا حتى نصل
الى الباقه الاقتصاديه الجديد هذه السنه
اللي هي الباقه الاقتصاديه اللي هي كان
حقيقه السعر جدا في متناول الجميع السنه
هذه من الامور الجديد اللي اضفناها
لشركات او لمعلومات اللي هي خاصه بالشركات
اللي هي طبيعه الخدمه التي تقدم البعد
والقرب من جسر الجمرات موقع المخيم في
مينا وفي عرفات وبالتالي يكون في عنده
تصور الحاج قبل الحجز من الشركه اللي
اختارها
من شان اظافر العربيه ان التسجيل لاداء
مناسك الحج هذا العام سيكون عبر منصتين
الاولى منصه نسك والثانيه عبر البوابه
الالكترونيه للوزاره طبعا المنصه هي
بطبيعتها هذه السنه حتى تنزل على الشريحه
على نمطين النمط الاولاني اللي هو على
منصه نسك ولا يمكن الجميع يعرفها الان
كانت في السابع كانت اسمها اتمنى لكن الان
ب- ب- بشكل جديد والحديث والعصري اللي هي
منصه مسك اللي تحتوي على العديد من
الخدمات ان كانت خدمات تعريفيه او معلومات
او حتى تفاعليه مع ضيف الرحمن اما ساره
الاخر الثاني وهو المسار الموجود على منصه
وزاره الحج والعمره المنصه المسار
الالكتروني او من النص الكترونيه البوابه
الالكترونيه لوزاره الحج والعمره وهي تعطي
رافدين للدخول للخدمات الالكترونيه وهذه
الامور التي تسهل خدمه ضيف الرحمن في الحج
حتى داخل المنصه تجد انه الجديده السنه
هذه لمقدمين خدمه نقدمها لاول مره وهو
الدفع عبر دفعات متتاليه كنا في السابق
انه يجب على ضيف الرحمن ان يدفع المبلغ
مباشره لتاكيد حجزه الان عنده خيار
الاولاني يدفع كامل المبلغ من اول 72 ساعه
الخيار الاخر الثاني انه ممكن انه يجزئه
على ثلاثه اجزاء الجزء الاولاني يدفعوا
خلال 72 ساعه الجزء الثاني يدفع بعد شهرين
والجزء الثالث هو هيكون ان شاء الله باذن
الله في شوالي تاكيد حجه
نناقش بعد الفاصل
الشؤون الاسلاميه في السعوديه تعلنون رصد
التعديات على عدادات المياه وكهرباء عدد
من مساجد العاصمه
احييكم من جديد اكد رئيس اركان الجيش
الباكستاني الفريق الاول عاصم منير خلال
لقائه بوزير الدفاع السعودي الامير خالد
بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض وذلك بمناسبه تعيينه
رئيسا لاركان الجيش الباكستانيه اكد على
قوتي ومتانتي العلاقات الثنائيه بين
البلدين الشقيقين كما بحث الجانبان
التعاون العسكري والدفاع وسبل دعمهما
اضافه الى استعراض الموضوعات الاقليميه
والدوليه ذات الاهتمام المشترك
في السعوديه رصدت ادارته حمايه مرافق
المساجد وخدماتها في الرياض العديد من
التعديات على عدادات الكهرباء وشبكه
المياه
الخاصه بالجوامع والمساجد ومرافقها اشتملت
التعدي على سحب اسلاكن من عداد الكهرباء
وتوصيلها لاحد المستودعات المجاوره للمسجد
اضافه الى التعدي على خزان المياه وسحب
الماسوره منه وتوصيلها لاحدى الاستراحات
المجاوره اضافه الى تعدي بعض المحاله
التجاريه القريبه من المسجد على عداده
لتستفيد من التيار الكهربائي الخاص
بالمسجد
ينضم الينا هاتفيا مساعد متحدث وزاره
الشؤون الاسلاميه والدعوه والارشاد عبد
الله العنزي اهلا بك معنا استاذ عبد الله
بدايه لتحدث عن اليه رصد هذه المخالفات ما
هي الاليه تحديدا التي تتبعونها في هذا
الاجراء
مشاهد قناه العربيه بدايه
انطلاقا من المسؤوليه
وزاره الشؤون الاسلاميه
في العنايه في بيوت الله عز وجل والاهتمام
بها حيث تحمل الوزاره في اهتمام مباشر من
معالي الوزير الدكتور عبد اللطيف ال الشيخ
للقيام برسالتها السامه في خدمه بيوت الله
والعنايه بها همم هنالك مصارين لرصد
التعديات على املاك المساجد حيث ان المسار
الاول هو عبر الجولات الرقابيه التي يقوم
بها المراقبون والمراقبات في مختلف مناطق
المملكه حيث يقوم المراقب بضبط حالات
التعدي وتوفيقها واعداد المحاضر الرسميه
للرف بها لجهات المختصه وهناك تعاون
وتنسيق مستمر مع الجهات الامنيه في ذلك
اما المسار الثاني فيتم
برفض المخالفات عبر البلاغات التي يتقدم
بها المواطنون بالاتصال عبر مركز التلقي
البلاغات اسلاميه واحد تسعه ثلاثه ثلاثه
الذي يعمل على مدار الساعه او من خلال
زياره المواطن
الفروع بالمناطق لتقديم البلاغات والتي
يتم معها التعاون بسريه تامه والتاكد منها
ميدانيا عبر لجان مختصه تعمل على ارض
الميدان ويتم توفي
ق والرفع بهذه الجهات المختصه بعد اشعار
الوزاره
الكثير من هذه المخالفات اليس هناك اليه
ربما واضحه لرصد اي مخالفات او زياده او
اختلاف في استهلاك الكهرباء والمياه
للمساجد
بتنسيق معها
الادارات به الفروع بمتابعه عدادات
الكهرباء
ارتفاع الاستهلاك فيها
وهذا يشير الى وجود التحدي على العدادات
ويقوم المراقب في زياره المسجد والوقوف
على المسجد وهمم متابعه هل هناك تعدل على
اعماق المسجد الوزاره يعني الى هذا اليوم
همم رصدت اكثر من 2500 حاله التحدي على
عدادات الكهرباء من قبل ضعف النفوس الذين
لا يراعون حرمه المال العام ولا حرمه
المساجد همم
الوزاره باشراف ومتابعه دقيقه من معالي
الوزير الدكتور عبد اللطيف ال الشيخ اداره
مختصره لحمايه الاملاك المساجد وتعمل هذه
الاداره بالتنسيق مع كافه فروع همم
الوزاره بمناطق المملكه وعلى مدار الساعه
رقصه متابعه عدادات الكهرباء والمياه
وال ايضا الرفع بالمخالفات والتعدي
والتنفي مع الجهات المختصه كذلك
ودنا نشير استاذه فاطمه من المخالفات ليست
مقصوره على عدادات المياه والكهرباء بل
الوزاره الان تعمل على ايضا همم
وتعديات على مرافق المساجد من الاراضي
واستغلال السكن الامام والمؤذن ومرافق
الوزاره وحتى مواقف السيارات الخاصه فيها
في الوزاره تابع وتعمل بجد عبر اللجان
المختصه التي تعمل على ارض الميدان
برتبهان استاذ عبد الله انا كنت اود ان
اسالك عنها ولكن اسالك عن ضعفاء النفوس
كما سميتهم او المخالفين همم في هذا همم
في هذه النقطه تحديدا كيف يتم محاسبتهم ما
الاجراءات ضد ضد
المخالفه من حين بدا المخالفه فعلى سبيل
المثال ال- ال- الوزاره منذ انشاء همم
اداره حمايه المرافق المساجد بتوجيهات
ومتابعه معالي الوزير ضبطت تضبط المخالفات
ويتم محاسبه همم المتعدين من حين بدء
المخالفه مثلا على سبيل المثال كانت
المخالفه قبل عشر سنوات الى هذا اليوم يتم
محاسبه
المتعدي باثر رجعي بالتنسيق مع الجهه
المختصه واحتساب يعني كميات استهلاك
الكهرباء والمياه خلال السنوات الماضيه
ومحاسبته الى حين ضبط المخالفه بالتنسيق
مع الجهات المختصه وفقا
استاذ عبد الله انا لا اعلم ان ان كان
يمكننا ان نسمي هذه التعديات ربما الان
بالظاهره لكثرتها
الى اي مدى الكاميرات او او تركيب
الكاميرات في المساجد يمكن ان يعني يساهم
في تقنين هذه التعديات على المساجد
اغلب المساجد ولله الحمد
النكيب الكاميرات الكاميرات المراقبه
وتعمل الوزاره الى جانب يعني الكاميرات
المراقبه ايضا بضبط المخالفات همم التي
همم
[موسيقى]
التعدي على املاك المساجد من قبل بعض
المواطنين وحتى
بعض مساجد لان الوزاره يعني وبتوجيهات
مباشره من معالي وزير الدكتور عبد اللطيف
ال الشيخ ارسلت تعاميم متتاليه على منسوب
المساجد بضروره التعاون مع الوزاره في
الابلاغ عن المخالفات
ومن يستغل الموارد المساجد لمصالحها
الشخصيه همم
هنالك الى الحمل تعاون من اصحاب الفضيله
ائمه المساجد في مقتل المناطق محافظه
المملكه وايضا هذه يعني تعاون مع الوزاره
الوزاره الداخليه الاجراءات الرسميه همم
سواء ان كان هو مباشر لهذا الحاله او
متعاون مع من باشر هذه الحاله والتحدي على
املاك المساجد الوزاره لم تتسامح مع كل من
يشتغل موارد المساجد والملاكها الخاصه
بمصالحها الشخصيه
همم تحاسب كل من يقصر في عمله وهذه
التعليمات عليها معاني
الاستجابه لاي بلاغات تقدم حول هذه
الاعتداءات
اللجان تعمل على مدار الساعه هنالك رجال
ميدانيه الاتصال الموحد هنالك تعاون حقيقه
من المواطنين والحمد الجميع
المسؤوليه هي مسؤوليه الجميع للمساج في
بيوت الله عز وجل والواجب الموقع على جميع
المواطنين والمقيمين عن اي تصير او اي
جوانب يعني تخلف باداء رساله المسجد في
المجتمع كذلك الاستغلال الموارد هذه
المساج اللي مصالحهم الشخصيه همم كما
اتلفت من ضيعات النفوس الذي لا يروحون
حرمه المال العام ولا حرمه هذه
بيوت الله عز وجل والقدسيهتها شكرا لك
الشؤون الاسلاميه والدعوه والارشاد عبد
الله العنزي على هذه المداخله
حددت هيئه الزكاه والضريبه والجمارك في
السعوديه معيار اختيار المنشات المستهدفه
في المجموعه الثانيه لتطبيق مرحله الربط
والتكامل من الفوتره الالكترونيه وتشمل
المنشات التي تتجاوز ايراداتها الخاضعه
لضريبه القيمه المضافه نصف مليار ريال
خلال عام 20 21 وستبدا هيئه الزكاه
والضريبه السعوديه يوليو المقبل في ربطه
وتكامل انظمه الفوتر الالكترونيه لدى كافه
المنشات المشموله في المجموعه الثانيه في
المنصه
ينضم الينا من الرياضه المتحدث باسمي هيئه
الزكاه والضريبه والجمارك حمود الحربي
اهلا بك معنا السيد حمود في نشره الرابعه
المرحله الثانيه من الفوتره تبدا الان
بالفعل ما نقات الاختلاف بينها وبين
المرحله التي سبقتها
الله جميع مشاهدين قناه العربيه طبعا هذه
المرحله اسميناها مرحله الربط والتكامل
بدا تطبيقها من واحد واحد 20 23
تختلف عن المرحله السابقه في عده معايير
المرحله الاولى التي بدات في اربعه ديسمبر
20 21 هذا كانت هي مرحله اصدار وحفظ
الفواتير والاشارات الدائمه والمدينه بشكل
الكتروني اي بمعنى ان خلال فتره الماضيه
في المرحله الاولى واجب على جميع المنشات
الخاطئه لضربه
[موسيقى]
والخادع لا احتفالات الكترونيه بوجود نظام
الكتروني يحفظ ويستر فواتير اشعارات
المدير بشكل الكتروني متناسب الان بدانا
في الثاني وهي كما ذكرت في بدايه مرحله
الربط والتكامل هذه المرحله لان مرحله
كبيره جدا وتحتاج تجهيزات عاليه جدا
والاختلاف الكبير في القطاعات في المملكه
هناك قطاعات كبيره ومتوسطه وصغيره فراينا
ان يتم تطبيق هذه المرحله بشكل تدريجي
بمعنى ان نحدد مجموعات كل مجموعه نحددها
معايير معينه يتم ابلاغها قبل سته اشهر
فالمجموعه الاولى حددناها في واحد يونيو
20 22 هذه المجموعه حددناها وفقا
الايرادات الثانويه الخاضعه يعني ضريبه
القيمه المضافه وفقا لقوائم 20 21 ومن
زادت ايراداته وفقا لتلك الايرادات وفقا
لتلك القواعد عن ثلاثه مليار ثانويه هذا
اصبح من المجموعه الاولى واصبح بدايه من
هذه السنه ملزم بالربط والتكامل مع الهيئه
ابلغناهم قبل سته اشهر وهذا ده لانه في
هذه المرحله كل المجموعات المحددها نعطيها
سته اشهر للالتزام همم
للتجهيز لهذه
متطلبات هذه التي تتحدث عنها
المطلوبه من المنشات لاكتمال هذا التكامل
والربط بين بينهم
هل تسمعني استاذ حمود
كنت اسالك عن متطلبات اللي تحتاجونها من
المنشات لاتمام هذا الربط والتكامل
من خلال تواصل مع المطور الخدمات
الالكترونيه الخدمات الحلول الفوت
الكترونيه التجهيز لهذا الامر وضع
المواصفات والمعايير لهذه المرحله الربط
والتكامل ولله الحمد دعمت القطاع الخاص
بهذه المرحله والمرحله الاولى ايضا لان
نرى ان هذا مشروع كبير وله اثر ايجابي على
القطاع والاقتصاد السعودي بصفه عامه همم
اخترنا ادله ارشاديه سواء مواصفات الفنيه
التقنيه والتشريعيه ايضا قمنا باعداد مواد
تعليميه فيديوهات توعويه ايضا عقدنا عدد
مرشد العمل لتوضيح اليه التجهيز لهذه
المرحله وما هي الضوابط
وتطلبات لهذه المرحله ايضا وضعنا منصه هي
منصه مطور والانظمه هذه المنصه يستطيع
المكلف الكترونيه مع مطور الخدمات
الالكترونيه الدخول على هذه المنصه واجراء
اختبار الكتروني
التاكد هل هو يتوافق مع تلكم متطلبات او
لا يتوافق ويعدل هذه المتطوره
طيب ماذا عن بقيه المنشات يعني المكلفه
الاخرى متى يمكن ان تنضم لهذه المرحله من
الفوتره
نعم الان على اعداد معايير قد نستمر في
معيار الايرادات الماليه ولكن كما ذكرت في
بدايه حديثي القطاع القطاع الخاص في
المملكه قطاع كبير ومتشعب وله طوائف عديده
بالتالي لمرحله الثانيه حددناها الان سوف
نبدا بتحديد المرحله الثالثه في وقت لاحق
بمشيئه الله ومن ثم نقوم بتحديد كل مجموعه
محدده قد نبدا بالايرادات وقد نرى معايير
اخرى تتوافق مع هذا القطاع وانشطته همم
فئته ك- نشاط اقتصادي اشكرك ان الرياضه
متحدث باسم هيئه الزكاه والضريبه والجمارك
حمود الحربي
[موسيقى]
قامت السعوديه بتسليم كل من مصر وفلسطين
حصتهما من لحوم الاضاحي والهدي من خلال
برنامج يشرف عليه البنك الاسلامي للتنميه
واستفادت 27 دوله من البرامج هذا العام
الذي يعود للتوزيع خارج السعوديه
اليوم في سفاره المملكه العربيه السعوديه
في القاهره تتلقى كل من مصر وفلسطين
نصيبهم من الهدي والاضاحي ضمن 27 دوله
تستفيد من المشروع هذا العام السفير
السعوديه استضاف نظيره الفلسطيني وممثلا
عن مصر في حضور مسؤول من البنك الاسلامي
للتنميه المشرف على مشروع السعوديه
للافاده من الهدي والاضاحي
لا تقتصر فقط على محيطها الداخلي في
الموقع السعوديه ولكن همم تمتد لتشمل
الدول العربيه يا صديقي الشقيقه
والدول الصديقه وهذا مشروع جيد ومشروع طيب
ومبارك
مشروع تكافل في ما بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه واشقها في الدول العربيه والدول
الاسلاميه
والسلطات المصريه لتسليم دوله فلسطين لحوم
الهدي والاضاحي برا من خلال منفذ رفح ليتم
توزيعها في قطاع غزه
خصص مشروع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والاضاحي كميه من اللحوم الى المستحقين في
جمهوريه مصر العربيه الشقيقه والبالغ
عددها 12,000 ذبيحه كذلك تم تخفيض كميه
اخرى لمستحقين بدوله فلسطين الشقيقه
والبالغه عدد 12 الف ذبيحه وجميع موزعها
ومغلفه ومعبه ومحفوظه ومتكتنه البنك
الاسلامي ما شاء الله هم عاملينها بطريقه
مبسطه جدا وسهله انها تبقى وحدات صغيره
تتوزع همم للناس على طول مباشره
او المصريين في ظل موجات الغلاء المتلاحقه
على الجميع وفي لنفسه تعتبر تكريسا لتقليد
تكافليا مستمر بين السعوديه واشقائها تامر
نصره العربيه القاهره
في السعوديه عن جمع قرابه الثلاثه مليارات
ريال محققت الاستفاده لاكثر من 4 ملايين
في 23 مجال بمشاركه اكثر من 1700 جمعيه
خيريه في مختلف مناطق السعوديه
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
فيديو يوثقوا تساقط الثلوج على مرتفعات
جبل اللوز في نيوم شمال غرب السعوديه
[موسيقى]
هناك المئات من المتظاهرين ما زالوا
يدخلون تحدثت عن الاشتباكات لليوم الثاني
على التوالي هو قرار سياسي على الايرانيين
والامريين ان يصل للحفظها ويقول فيها انها
مستعدون للتوقيع على الاتفاق مره ثانيه
تتوجه روسيا بشكل متزايد الى الصين والهند
الشريكين قدميين
المفتوحه لاخر التطورات التي تحدث الان في
العراق
الكويت انضم الينا مراسل العربيه عادي
العيدان
[موسيقى]
ام لا الجمر ما زال تحت الرامات كما يقال
ما الذي حدث حقيقه
هذه بعض المشاهد
هي اسلوب حياه للملايين
[تصفيق]
في شغفها وحماستها بسرعتها وجرعتها
[موسيقى]
كره القدم العربيه والعالميه
حول العالم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذه المدينه التي تم حصارها لاكثر من
الشهر
هنا في هذه الحفره سقطت القذيفه
هذا هو مسرح وسينما المدينه حصريا لقناتي
العربيه والحدث نرصد ما حدث في هذه القريه
واثار القتال
احييكم من جديد اقيم في العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض حفل جائزه التميز الاعلامي لعام 20
22 في نسختها الثالثه وشاهدت الجائزه هذا
العام واصول 30 مشاركه الى المرحله
النهائيه من اجمالي الف مشاركه تنفست على
الفوز بالجائزه في 90 مسارات اعلاميه فيما
استحدثت جائزه جديده او استحدثت لتكريم
الشخصيات التي تركت بصمتها في الاعلام
السعوديه وهم الشاعر ابراهيم خفاجي كاتبوا
كلمات النشيد الوطني والفنان محمد عبده
بالاضافه الى المصور بندر الجود والمصور
الفرنسي شيكو مينوزا
[موسيقى]
مو جزء رياضي مع محمد القناص
شكرا جزيلا فاطمه اخبار الرياضه حياكم
الله قررت لجنه المسابقات في رابطه الدوري
السعودي للمحترفين تاجيل لقاء النصر وظيفه
الطائي والذي كان من المقربي قامته اليوم
ضمن مباريات الجوله الثانيه عشره من
مسابقه الدوري السعودي ليقامه غدا الجمعه
في نفس التوقيت عند الساعه السادسه مساءا
وجاء التسجيل بناءا على خطاب رئيس مجلس
اداره شركه الوسائل السعوديه القاضي بعدم
قدره الملعب مرسي في جامعه الملك سعود على
استضافه اللقاء نظرا لغزاره الامطار التي
ادت الى اعطال كهربائيه باناره الملعب
والبوابات الالكترونيه
ويتم تاجيل حرصا على سلامه اللاعبين
والحضور في الملعب
ويسعى الشباب اليوم الى خطف نقاط مضيفه
الوحده على ملعب مدينه الملك عبد العزيز
الرياضيه بمكه المكرمه في مباراه يطمح
فيها اصحاب الارض الى الابتعاد عن مؤخرتي
الترتيب والضيوف للبقاء ضمن المنافسين على
الصداره واتراجع الوحده الى المركز الثالث
عشر برصيد 90 نقاط وله مباراه مؤجله امام
الفتح بينما ينفرد والشباب في المركز
الثاني برصيد 25 نقطه مع مؤجله امام
الاتحاد
ويتواجه الاتحاد والهلال اليوم في كلاسيكو
الكره السعوديه ضمن مباريات الجوله
الثانيه عشر من الدوري على ملعب مدينه
الملك عبد الله الرياضيه في جده ويقع
الاتحاد في المركز الثالث برصيد 40 وعشرين
نقطه بعد عشر مباريات واخرى مؤجله مع
الشباب بينما يحتل الهلال والمركز الخامس
برصيد اثنتين و 20 نقطه من 11 مباراه
اخرها التعادل مع ضمك ويبحث الهلال عن
الفوز بعد التعثر في الجولتين الماضيتين
اينما يستمتع الاتحاد بسلسله من النتائج
الايجابيه اذ لم يخسر اي مباراه في الموسم
حتى الان
دعج يعني فانتينو رئيس الاتحاد الدولي
لكره القدم للتضامن مع ثنائي فريق ليتشي
صامويل اومتيتي ولاميك باندا حيث اذان
الاساءات العنصريه التي تعرض لها الثنائي
انا اثناء مواجهه لاتسيو في مباراه الدوري
الايطالي امس الاربعاء وعبر انفانتينو عن
طريق حسابي على الانستغرام عن تضامنه معهم
تيتي وباندا متمنيا ان تقف الغالبيه
العظمى من المشجعين الطيبين لاسكات كل
العنصريين مره واحده والى الابد
تختتم الخميس الجوله التاسعه عشره للدوري
الانجليزي الممتاز لكره القدم بلقاء
تشيلسي اما نظيفه مانشستر سيتي في ملعب
السامسونج جريدج في لندن
نقطه في ميلادي تشيلسي 25
اخر مباراه جماعه الفريقين كانت في نوفمبر
الماضي في ذلك كاس الرابطه فاز بها سيتي
بهدفين دولارات
تاهل برشلونه الى ثمن نهائي كاس ملك
اسبانيا بعد فوز صعب على مضيفه احد فرق
الدرجه الثالثه امس الاربعاء
من برشلونه كتالونيا الى الكانتي فالنسيا
حملت معها رباعيه وفوز بشق الانفس تفاد به
المدرب الشعبي خروجا للمسابقه الكاس بدون
ليفاندوفسكي والتير شتيجن استهلا برشلونه
المباراه بافضل ما يكون هدفه في الدقيقه
الرابعه اعطى املا بنتصارا كبير
صمد اصحاب الارض في باقي دقائق الشوط
الاول وانتظر انتر سيتي حتى مطلع الشوط
الثاني يدرك التعادل في مرمى الحارس
فيناستوريس صاحب الهدف سولد فيلا كان
السابقا يلعب في الشباب برشلونه بين 2018
و 2020
يعني للضيوف في مرمى الحارس كابوس
وعاد اللاعب
يضيفه الثانيه اهداف اصحاب الارض واسطه
فرحه الجماهيريه كبيره
متر سيتي
الهدف الثالث لبرشلونه وبدا بان البرازيلي
ابطل مفعوله مفاجاه فريق الدرجه الثالثه
قبل النهايه بثلاثه عشر دقيقه
مجددا سولف الى رفض الاستسلام واكمل
الهاتريك الشخصي له في الدقيقه السادسه
والثمانين الوقت الاصلي ينتهي والتعادل
يجبر بطل كاس في 31 مناسبه على حوض شوطين
اضافيين
وتصديات الحارس وخشباته الثلاث الحسم جاء
اخيرا بتوقيت انسوا فاتي في الدقيقه
الثالثه بعد المئه انتصارا تاخر لكنه
عندما تحقق عادل الفريق الكتالوني الى
مقره برباعيه اكدت التاهل الى ثمن النهائي
الامور في الشوط الاصلي
كما تاهل اشبيليا الى ثمني نهائي مسابقه
كاس ملك اسبانيا بعد فوزه الكبير على
مضيفه
ليناريست ديبورتيفو بخمسه اهداف
كان نصيب المهاجم المغربي يوسف النصيري
ثلاثه اهداف
مما سجل الفريق الاندلسي في هذه المباراه
[موسيقى]
الرابع اليك فاطمه
شكرا محمد عناد الشمري مو سنن سعودي في
محافظه رفحاء بمنطقه الحدود الشماليه احب
الابل ولازم رعايتها منذ اكثر من سبعه
عقود حتى اورث هذا الولاء لابنائه واحفاده
الكاميرا العربيه التقته عند ابنه برفقه
الزميل الجزاء النماصي الذي وافانا
بالتفاصيل
[موسيقى]
بهذه اللغه الرمزيه اعتاد العب مع نادي
الشمري ندبه بين فيافي محافظه رفحاء
بمنطقه الحدود الشماليه السعوديه منذ اكثر
من سبعه عقود
امهاتها غاليات عندي والله ما وقفت بوسطه
[موسيقى]
والعلياء اسمائه لهذه النقطه والشعر التي
شاركت في عده مسابقات وحصلت على مراكز
متقدمه الخامسه
واللي بيعتزل
عبد العزيز الله يرحمه
والمزاينات
ربع
واذكر ابني
عاما من عمره خلف ابله والرثه هذا الولع
لابنائه واحفاده
جدا
ياخذني معه
صار اكنها خبز اول نشوف انه يجن
ن
عناد الشمري ان يجمع احبابه في نزهه بريه
واصطحنين الابل من سنار جيصومت فيحان جزاع
النماصي العربيه
اهم الامطار الشتويه هي الامطار الوسميه
ومدتها 92 يوما التفاصيل مع خالد ازعاج في
تقويم
[موسيقى]
نزول المطر في موسمه سهيل الوسم
المربعانيه الشبط وتتابع نزوله وكثره
الايام المشمسه هذه مقومات السنه الربيعيه
واول الربيع البادر ظهوره يتوقف على اول
مطره فاذا نزل المطر بل الوسم فانه يظهر
سريعا لان الاجواء دافئه واذا نزل المطر
بالمربعانيه فانه يتاخر كثيرا لان الاجواء
بارده فالمربعنيه تكبر النبت ولا تجعله
يتنفس واذا امطرت السماء بسته امطار سينيه
خلال موسم سهيل والوسم والمربعانيه فانها
سنه ربيعيه وثلاثه امطار شبه ربيعيه واقل
من ذلك سنه مجدبه يعد الرياضه الحياه
والارض مجربه رزقا وفي البحر ذيل السحبي
مسحوب والرزقه وان لم يسع صاحبه اجمل ولكن
شقاء المرئي
مكتوب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
واهم الامطار الشتويه هي الامطار الوسميه
ومدتها 92 يوما فالعشرين يوما الاخيره من
موسم سهيل واثنين وخمسين يومنا الوسم
والعشرين يوما الاولى من موسم المربعانيه
هذه الفتره مبيته لكل شيء حتى الفقع بين
قوسين الكماء واهم الامطار الصيفيه هي
الامطار الهاريثيه وهي التي تاتي في اخر
موسم الصيف وهي المسببه لغزاره الامطار
الشتويه ما هو الا له سبب يبتدي منه
ويتشعبوا فتنت قلبي محجبه وجهها بالحسن
منتقبه
[موسيقى]
في ختام الرابعه نذكر بالعناوين
العربيه ترصد الاوضاع على حدود اوكرانيا
مع بيلاروسيا في ظل مخاوفكييف من هجمات
حدوديه
الحد السعوديه تعلن بدا تسجيل حجاج الداخل
ضمن اربع عباقات تبدا تكلفتها من 4000
ريال
الشؤون الاسلاميه في السعوديه تعلن الرصد
تعديات على عدادات المياه والكهرباء في
مساجد في العاصمه
احسان السعوديه تعلن عن تجاوز التبرعات
المليارين و 900 مليون ريال في اكثر من
ثلاثه وعشرين مجالا
وفيديو يوثق تساقط الثلوج على مرتفعات جبل
اللوز في نيوم شمال غرب السعوديه
في امان الله
[موسيقى]